[Music]  Hudson was also there and check her out  with designer Michael Kors and her buddy  Gwyneth Paltrow Kate had so much praise  and love for gwennyth for going public  with her claims about being harassed by  Harvey Weinstein to speak up meantime  Weinstein resigned today from the board  of The Weinstein Company after an  expected showdown to challenge his  firing his brother Bob and other members  voted to uphold his termination while  Weinstein remains in Arizona receiving  treatment no comment and while Weinstein  had previously stated he hoped to quote  rebuild his relationship with a strange  wife Georgina Chapman a source tells ET  quote there is not a chance in hell she  will ever take Harvey back never  [Music]